Speaker 1: Okay. Last thing on yesterday's
testimony in the January six committee hearings
by Cassidy Hutchinson. And this has nothing to
do with Cassidy Hutchinson herself. Liz Cheney
yesterday during the committee hearings at
the end revealed that in Mafia mob boss style,
Trump associated individuals have been contacting
witnesses and sort of suggesting to them,
you should remain loyal. Be careful what
you say. Here is Liz Cheney revealing
what is quite clearly witness tampering, the
intimidation of January six committee witnesses.
Speaker 3: Here is how one witness described
phone calls from people interested in that
witnesses testimony. Well, what they said to me
is as long as I continue to be a team player,
they know I'm on the right team. I'm doing
the right thing. I'm protecting who I need
to protect. You know, I'll continue to stay
in good graces in Trumpworld. And they have
reminded me a couple of times that Trump does
read transcripts. And just keep that in mind as I
proceed through my interviews with the committee.
Speaker 1: Remember, Trump reads transcripts.
That's intimidation. That's witness tampering.
Speaker 3: Here's another sample in a different
context. This is a call received by one of
our witnesses. Quote a person. Let me know.
You have your deposition tomorrow. He wants
me to let you know he's thinking about you.
He knows you're loyal and you're going to do the
right thing when you go in for your deposition.
Speaker 1: Right. You're
going to do the right thing.
Speaker 3: I think most Americans know that
attempting to influence witnesses to testify
truthfully presents very serious concerns.
Speaker 1: Yes. And so this is the latest. Even
within. So the the hearings are looking at what
took place and may find that crimes took place
in relation to the hearings. It appears as
though more criminality is taking place. Our
friend Jamie Raskin recently appeared on our
program. Congressman Jamie Raskin was asked
about this and its potential criminality. And
here is what he had to say of witness tampering.
Speaker 5: The. Well, the evidence of witness
tampering that the committee has released or
the two episodes that the vice chair cited
today anonymously for obvious reasons.
It's a crime to tamper with witnesses.
Correct. Form of obstructing justice.
The committee won't tolerate it. And we
haven't had a chance to fully investigated
or fully discuss it. But it's something on our.
Speaker 1: Agenda, folks. There may be people
charged with crimes in relation to the committee,
like they think about the multilayered insanity
of that. You've got the subject matter being
investigated by the committee, which could lead to
criminal charges, but you could have subsequently
an investigation into Trump worlds actions related
to the investigative committee. And there may
be crimes there. It's crimes all the way down,
seemingly unbelievable what is going on? We're
going to take a quick break. We're going to get
to other stories, including new polling about
the 2022 midterms and much more. Stay with me.